How do you stay calm
when they're not?
When somebody is yelling at you, they're
mad at you, they're angry, they are
shouting,
what do you do in that moment? In
today's episode, I am going to teach
you. I'm going to teach you number one,
how to get them to lower their volume.
Two, we're going to add space into the
conversation. We're going to talk how to
do that to regulate our emotions and
theirs. And three, I'm going to give you
phrases that you can use that is going
to help calm and smooth out the
situation for a much more productive
conversation. You ready?
You didn't ask for it. You didn't plan
for it, but you're in it now. The other
person across from you talking is not
talking as much as they are throwing
their words in your face. They're
shouting, they're yelling, it's hurting
your ears, you're scared, you don't know
what to do. How do you handle the
situation when somebody is yelling at
you? Number one, this what I want you to
do. Number one, you are going to refuse
to raise your voice. When somebody's
yelling at you, one of the worst things
you can do
is start to turn up the volume on your
voice. That's what our default wants to
do. When somebody's yelling,
what do you do? They try and talk over
them. You have to yell over them. You
have to If they're at a level 10, you
have to crank it up to a level 18. Then
it becomes a a play for dominance. Who
is the one who can out-yell the other?
Who is the one who can scare the threat
away?
That is a weak position. And and I'm
going to tell you why. The people who
yell,
it tells the other person
that they're winning. It tells the other
person that they've got you.
It gives them that sense of control. It
gives them that that hit of dopamine. It
is telling them that, "Hey, I am now
pushing their buttons so badly that they
are in this state of fight or flight,
this fear where they are yelling
and I now have the control and the
emotion. I'm the one that's still in it.
It's a bad game to play. I want you to
think of a like a music that's really
loud in the room. What do you kind of
have to do? Maybe you're in the car,
maybe you're at the house. You have to
yell over it. Nobody can really hear
what you're saying because there's this
really loud undertone that's filling all
the space. Yeah, that's the other
person's voice in this instant. You're
not listening to them and they're
definitely not listening to you. All
right, so I the yelling matches, you
know, you have experience with this, we
all do. The yelling matches don't do
anything except tire out our systems.
They I mean they just tire us out.
Eventually, the yelling has to stop and
now you're kind of out of breath and now
you're tired and now you feel not just
emotionally drained, you also feel
physically drained because you gave away
your power. You gave away that control.
You exerted that energy rather than
protecting it and conserving it. So, how
do you do that? How do you do that in
the moment? You refuse to raise your
voice. That means if somebody's yelling
at a 10, you're going to stay right here
at a one.
Maybe you're at a three.
Maybe you're at a one.
It's
the reason why it it works so well is
because people will mirror what they
see.
Naturally, they don't even know what's
happening. If you're yelling and I'm
staying right here, you're going to do
one of two things. One, you're either
going to get frustrated at me because
you're realizing that you can't control
me and that's frustrating.
Uh or two,
you're naturally going to pull down your
voice because you're going to hear the
the discrepancy.
That's That's kind of a bigger word.
It's the difference. You can hear the
difference, the discrepancy, the the big
um from the gap between where they're at
and where you're at. And they're going
to feel like they're overexposed. Like
you There's a reason why people don't
just yell in a quiet room.
Because it's it's calling all the
attention to them. They feel
overexposed.
In a big gym when it's if everybody's
quiet or maybe it's a at church or
whatever it is. Now there are places
that are preserved because they are
religious places or whatever it is.
Nobody yells at these because it is
calling all the attention. They're going
to feel overexposed whatever they said
everybody's going to hear it. People
don't like that. Even in one-on-one
settings because they feel like what
they're saying is being overexposed and
nobody's listening.
Hey, it just to yell to yell doesn't do
any good. So they'll naturally start to
pull their volume
down. That's how you do that. Doesn't
matter how high they go.
You stay at a three. You stay at a one.
I know that's hard to do. It's really
hard to do in the moment, but I promise
you it is telling them that you are the
one in control. You are the one that is
unbothered. That you're the one that is
not threatened by their behavior. You
know how much of a power move that is?
It's a huge. Two.
It's not just a volume I want you to be
able to turn down.
It's the regulation of emotions. How do
you get people to naturally start to go,
"Whoo, okay. Yeah, all right. Now I'm
I'm getting back into the mode. Now I'm
I'm feeling like my normal self."
Instead of being the Hulk, they're now
Bruce Banner. They're they're back to
normal. All right, that's a Marvel
reference in case you're wondering.
Yeah, how do you do that?
You inject time into the conversation.
There's one thing that will help
regulate people's emotion more than
anything there is and that is time.
What matters right in this instant
probably doesn't matter so much later
tomorrow. You ever got an email that you
read and you get really upset about it?
You look at it again and read it the
next day, it hardly has the same effect.
Time has a way of solving things out.
You had a bad argument with someone,
3 years later, you're like, what did we
even argue about? Why did we I don't
even remember what we argued about. It
doesn't matter. Time has a way
of sifting out what is truly important
and essential and valuable in your life.
So, we're going to do that in the
conversation and you do that by what I
teach and anybody who's a fan of this
podcast knows
and anybody who's read the book, The
Next Conversation, knows
let your breath be the first word
that you say.
Whatever first word would be in your
response, use a breath. So, instead of
this, like when people snap, ever been
in a conversation somebody and somebody
snaps
and they say something like, you know
what would be really you would you know
what would be really nice? You know what
would be really nice? And all of a
sudden you go, okay, here we go. Lights
are on now. Now they're really
ratcheted up in in the conversation. The
snap happens. Whenever you inject time
as a way of slowing things down and it
keeps the emotional aspect of your mind
from taking a hold of the steering
wheel. Keeps your logical side in place
where you're very aware. You're much
more aware of your emotions, aware of
what you're saying. You're more
intentional and you choose your words
more wisely. When you're emotional, you
don't really care about your word
choice. You just you just say things. It
doesn't even matter to you if they make
sense. Ever been in an argument where
y'all are both just being so ugly that
you you're saying things that don't even
really make sense?
You're throwing words and you don't even
care what they mean. I don't care if
it's logical or not, they're just words.
They're just getting out.
You're going to do time. Inject time.
Use your breath and slow things down.
Here's a comparison.
Which one of these people
I say people, it's still me. Hey, it's
Jefferson. Which one of these voices
sound more in control
to you? Sound more calm
to you, somebody you want to listen,
somebody you want to follow, somebody
you want to mirror.
Here's voice one. I already I already
told you I'm not going to do that. I
already told you I'm not going to do
that, okay?
I already told you
I'm not going
to do that.
One or two?
Put it down there in the comments,
wherever you're listening. One or two?
Number one says I'm grasping for
control. Listen to me, I need all the
control. I've given it all up. Now I'm
trying to get it back. I already told
you I'm not going to do that.
Second voice says, nah.
I never lost control. I'm not losing it.
Never let it go.
I already told you
I'm not going to do that.
Not going to do that.
The second voice is always the one that
sounds more centered, more grounded.
Why? Because you're using time. So I
slowed my words down. It It's uh yeah, I
I
I turned down the volume of my words, so
I'm not yelling, but I slowed my words
down.
Yeah?
Much better. Using time to your
advantage. Number three,
we're going to use phrases. I'm going to
teach you some phrases
that are going to help
dissolve the tension, especially when
things are really heated like this. And
I'm I'm going to give you a frame to do
it in.
I I say frame. I'm going to give you a
few little
uh techniques. That I think is the best
word for me to put this. And this is a
technique that I learned from one of my
very good friends. Uh he's always been a
big role model of mine, and we've since
become very good friends. Chris Voss, he
has he has his book Never Split the
Difference, great book.
And what he does,
one of the FBI techniques is
people don't like to say yes to things,
they love to say no. No's our default.
We would like to say no to things. So,
you turn a question
to get a no
in exchange for them opening up, getting
more of what you want.
So, what we're going to do is use a
frame, begin the question to get a no
answer out of this. And how you get a no
is you begin with a negative in the part
of your sentence. I know I'm kind of
getting weird and technical here, but
this is the fun stuff that that I like.
I'm sure there's a button where you can
skip it 15 seconds and we'll get there.
All right, so if you want to add
uh
Let me rephrase that.
If you want to get the other person to
calm down, you're going to ask a
question to them that's going to get
them to say no because they're not going
to want to tell you yes. They're going
to want to say no. How we're going to do
that is at the beginning of your
sentence begin with a negative. Here are
some options that I like to eat to to
use. Are you against
Are you opposed
and is it unreasonable? Those are the
three that I like to mix up.
So, instead of saying
Can you please calm down?
You want them to say yes, right?
But they won't. They definitely don't
want to say yes to that.
Can't Can't you just calm down, please?
Can you just lower your voice?
Yeah, that's They're not going to want
to say, "Oh, yes. Yes, I will. I will
calm my voice. I just had a moment,
didn't I?" No, it's going to just
ratchet them up. They're going to get
more angry. You're going to tell me to
calm down? Calm down.
Not going to go well. Instead, when you
get the no, it's a whole lot easier. So,
it sounds like this.
Are you against us talking
just at a normal tone?
Or is it unreasonable to ask us to talk
without yelling?
Are you Are you opposed to having a
conversation
without us raising our voices?
Are you opposed to having a conversation
in a in a normal voice.
They're They're going to say naturally
no
to that. They're not going to They're
not going to say yes. If I were to say,
"Are you Is it unreasonable for us
to have a conversation in a normal
voice?"
Are they going to say yes? No, they're
not going to say yes to that. They're
going to say no.
Naturally, they're going to just kind of
calm down. They're going to melt in that
second. They're going to come down
several steps
to meet you more of where you are, more
in the one to three range, where they
were up in the the tens and twelves.
All right. Is it unreasonable for us to
have a conversation in a normal volume?
Probably, they're not even going to
answer you, most likely. They're going
to naturally just start to come down and
talk in a normal tone.
Cuz they don't want to tell you yes.
They want to say no. Whenever you start
with, "Are you against? Are you opposed?
Is it unreasonable?"
It's It's getting to the no response.
That's what you want in this instant,
cuz that's where they're wanting to say,
and now they're hearing you when you
combine it with you lowering your voice,
your volume, and slowing down your
words, and adding time to help regulate,
and then use a question that gets a no.
Like, "Are you Are you against us having
a conversation just
without the yelling?"
Is Is Is that something you're against?
They're not going to say no, or they're
not going to say yes to that.
All right? That's how you stay calm
when they aren't. It happens in every
relationship, in every
every facet of life, I feel like,
there's always going to be that, because
it's the emotional
It's the emotion out of every human.
It's natural. So, and sometimes, you
know what?
That person is us.
I'm the one that is having the big
emotional reaction. I'm the one that is
yelling. I'm the one that's doing that.
And sometimes, if somebody across me is
a mirroring
what good communication sounds like,
and the person across from me is slowing
down their words and not yelling and not
biting what I'm the the bait that I have
by yelling at them
it's going to calm me down, too. So,
it's it's it's part of all of us.
Cool. Before we keep going, I want to
take a moment to tell you about
Timeline. When we talk about aging well
or healthy aging, we usually first start
talking about diet or sleep or exercise.
And those are all great, but we can also
continue to look down at the cellular
level. If you remember mitochondria,
remember the powerhouse of the cell?
Well, it's true, they store cell energy.
And as we get older, those cells don't
deliver that energy nearly as
efficiently. They get damaged, they get
old, they get tired. Well, that's why I
take Mitopure from Timeline. It supports
something called mitophagy, which is
your body's natural process for clearing
out damaged mitochondria so your cells
can produce energy more efficiently.
Timeline has spent over 15 years
researching mitochondrial health and
human clinical studies. And people have
seen improvements in muscular strength
and energy without changing their
routine. So, for me, this is about
staying strong, staying sharp, and
feeling like myself as I continue to
age. And they come in these flavors that
are delicious. I only took two and then
realized on the bottle I could take
four, so I started taking four cuz
they're just that delicious. Timeline's
clinically proven formula is now
available at new lower price. You can go
to Mitopure now starts at $79 when you
go to timeline.com/jefferson.
Go to timeline.com/jefferson
to learn more. And now, let's keep
going.
>> What do you personally do when you get
frustrated in an argument? Or I mean,
you you've shared some things, but
uh have you just done it so much that
these are your go-to phrases when you
feel like someone's attacking you or
saying things that are just blatantly
wrong or blatantly a lie? I mean, when
that sense of justice kind of comes up
in you, how do you keep yourself calm?
>> How do I keep myself calm?
Breathing works
every time.
Um I am a big proponent of the breath.
Because I can tell in my shoulders
my shoulders are getting tense. That's
what happens. So, the traps, the my
muscles will get real tight. And I
realize, "What am I doing?" So, if I
breathe big breath in and out, that
helps me a lot to calm down. But, I also
tend to and this is just from
repetition.
I
am am
I like to detach myself from bad
arguments. So, I I like to kind of watch
them
third party kind of thing of
understanding what's what's happening in
that moment. So, when somebody's saying
bad stuff to me,
I picture myself having like a garbage
like trash can right here. So, when I I
get it, I just put it away. I never
allow it to
I don't allow myself to carry it. I
don't allow myself to take it
personally.
>> Yeah.
>> I hear it. I don't even I'm not even
putting it in my basket. I'm just
putting it in the trash.
And that image to me
helps keeps me a lot more calm so that
I'm not chasing
rabbit trails to to to to no man's land.
If I want to stay right on path, that's
one of the most frustrating things I
think for people when they get really
mad at in an argument
is the person who's being logical.
Uh because at that moment you want to be
emotional. You want them to be
emotional. You you have to find a way
that Oh, this is threatening to me. I
have to I fight or flight. I need to
fight you. I want to say something
hurtful. I want to throw something. This
is my fight mode saying I need to beat
you.
But, if you don't ever present yourself
as an opponent in a way to where they're
never able to rise to really to grab
onto something. Like if I yelled back at
you,
I've now just gave them a pedestal to
jump even further. If I say something
ugly, I've now just justified their
words. Now they get to grab for more
every time. But if I just never offer
that,
I diffuse it every time. And so often
I'll have other attorneys go, "Man, I I
I wish you weren't on this case or else
I'd be able to make, you know, I'd be
able to get a lot more passionate and
angry." And and they're just not able to
because I never I never provide them
that that rope. So breath works a lot.
Uh slowing my voice and my words down
help a lot.
Cuz slowing your words
is always
very
useful.
>> And calming.
>> And calming. Yeah, so it it calms it
calms them down. If I have somebody on
the phone uh or in front of me and
they're all worked up,
>> Mhm.
>> just for me to say, look at them and
say,
"I
hear
you."
Like
it don't matter who it is, they go, "Oh,
okay." Like I just they just want to
know that I'm acknowledging them often
times. And that that calms them down
pretty quickly.
>> Are there ever times though when you
want to
excite them? So instead of calming them
down, like you need them to actually be
a bit more passionate. And then what do
you do in those instances? Just the
opposite? Like talk faster?
>> Yeah, that's that's exactly right.
That's exactly right. So if I'm if I'm
wanting to amp somebody up, if I really
want to get things going, that I'm going
to talk a whole lot faster. And my my
volume's going to start to increase. And
I'm going to say, "Hey, look, I need you
to be engaged here with me. When I say
this, I need you to be that." And then
now I'm starting like get them elevated
because they're starting to match my
frequency, right? So that's that's what
I do.
>> That's right. It's like, "I'm all in,
Jefferson. Tell me, where are we going?"
>> Yeah, yeah. So I'm like, "Hey, we're
going to do this. Come on."
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> then they are um
now now they feel like, "All right,
we're on a team. Let's go. I'm ready to
just
run through a brick wall. So.
>> For sure.
>> Yeah.
>> What about for the people who
they've had an argument, it was
terrible, they did all the wrong things,
but they're wanting now to reset. So,
they're wanting to take a break and then
they're wanting to re-engage
>> Yeah.
>> in that same conversation. How do you
re-engage properly?
>> Um
let me clarify. Is have they
have they disengaged yet? Like there's
they're in separate rooms, they're not
talking to each other, and they want to
come back together.
>> That's a great question. Uh can we talk
about it with both? So, let's say
they've taken a time out, a specific
time out, but they're going to be coming
back together. And then let's talk about
um you're in the middle of it and you
realize this isn't going the way I want
it to.
How do you reset?
>> Okay, so I would
if they are separated, not talking to
each other.
This is a pretty I I'm going to make
this point real quick though, too.
When when they come together
a very open way of starting to just make
a runway for the other person to to come
together with you is to say
that was not my best self.
>> Mm.
>> Is is the admitting that was not that
was not my best moment.
>> Like that.
>> Yeah, just to have that
um you were taking ownership of the fact
that who I was was not who I wanted to
be right now.
>> Mm.
>> Often times in arguments
people will say, you know, what kind of
demeanor do I need to have?
You already have it, you just don't use
it. So, if you and I Kimberly, if you
and I are in an argument and we're just
hashing out it. I mean, we're just we're
saying things
and eventually
I say something that's gone one step too
far.
I hurt too much. I made a comment that I
knew would hurt because I wanted it to
hurt.
Um and
let's say you start to cry, I start to
cry, and we go in separate rooms. Then
we come back together 30 minutes later,
an hour later. How are we talking then?
We're a lot softer. Hey.
Hey.
I'm sorry I said that. It's not what I
meant. You I mean, you hear how the the
conversation now you sound softer. Now
you slow things down. Now you're
actually listening to what they have to
say coming at it from From my point of
view, this is what happened. Oh, well,
that's not what I didn't mean. From my
point of view
you you have all the tools, you're just
not You're not using them in that way.
But let's say they haven't separated
yet.
If
they're just hashing at it, somebody
needs to take a time out and say, "This
we're running in circles. This is more
harm than good right now. Can we take a
and put a time frame on it? Can we Can
we come back to this tomorrow or tonight
or in 30 minutes?
I just I think I just need to take a
walk for a second.
Like you Somebody needs to take the
responsibility of saying, "This is not
going anywhere. This is not helpful to
us. This is more This is doing more harm
than
than good.
And I think we need a reset."
Nothing wrong with that.
>> Mhm.
Love that. That's so
>> Yeah, as long as you make it clear that
this is not me This is not me giving up.
This is not me leaving the conversation.
I want to continue it, but I want to
continue it in a healthy way. Can you
You know, what's the chance you agree
with that?
And they'll say, "Yeah."
>> Yeah.
>> Maybe it's true.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. Maybe so.
>> Maybe so. Maybe so.
What I'm getting from a lot of the
things you've said and just kind of
summarizing
is it takes a lot of personal
self-awareness
and forward thinking to have good
communication. So, self-awareness and
maturity to be able to say to be able to
say, "Maybe you're right." or "Maybe
so." and not to get so defensive in the
moment. But, as well, I mean, I go back
to what you said of have a goal. Like,
what's the goal for the What's the goal
for the argument? What's the goal for
the conversation? And being able to
frame that on the front end
huge game-changer. That's something I'm
probably going to start using today. I'm
sure I'm going to encounter some
conversation today in my life where I'll
say, "Here's the goal, you know, here's
kind of the boundaries of it. Here's
what I want to see us get to, and it may
not be pretty every step along the way,
but I believe that we're on the same
team and can get there if we work
together."
>> Yeah, I I absolutely agree. Uh and one
thing that even that's very powerful to
say at the outset like that when you
want to reframe it, say, "Look,
I I need permission from you to say
things even if they don't make sense."
>> Mhm.
>> To say things even even even even if
uh it's venting or even if it's messy.
You know what I mean? You just I I need
you to understand I'm going to say
things that may not make sense to you,
but I need to just say them. And I don't
need you to respond yet. I just need to
be able to say them.
>> That's good.
>> You know, can you be in that with me? Um
but, I when we say like the bigger
themes of what we're talking about here
today
is yes, it's definitely good to have
that sense of
detachment,
being able to have a goal.
I would think a very big key is to
understand that
the person you see even at home, even
the person you live with, is often not
the person you're talking to.
Because you see them
at home busy doing this, doing that, but
that's just who you see, but who you're
talking to is the person that this
morning got really frustrated that their
hair was undone right and they got
self-conscious and they're having a bad
day or they had a text from their their
mother who set them off and got them
upset or they had something happen at
work that got them overly stressed or
maybe they got a bill in the mail that
they don't know about yet and they just
all of a sudden they got sent into
finances. The person you see is really
the really the person you're talking to.
So when you get into the argument side
of things
the more curious you are about what's
happening to them
rather than being so defensive of what's
being said to you it's like you reverse
engineer the conversation. Like when you
just have the capability of they say
something ugly you just like no that's
not that's not what I'm looking at. I
want I want to ask about you. What's
what's what's happening here? When
because once you find that that's there
you found the issue.
>> I love that.
>> Yeah.
>> I really love that. That's fantastic and
I'm sure I'll be able to use that today
too.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Some of the in some of the conversations
I'm going to have later.
>> If you cry in an argument or someone
else is crying or starts to cry at some
point, what's the best way to respond?
>> When somebody starts to cry when
>> When you're when you're having an
argument or a difficult conversation and
all of a sudden you start to cry or the
person you're arguing with starts to
cry. Okay, what's the best way to
respond if you cry or they cry?
So
if you're in an argument and you start
to cry
number one do not for one second
apologize. Don't There's absolutely
nothing that you need to say. Let me say
that differently.
If you begin to cry in an argument
the only response you need to have is
nothing. There's no apology you need to
issue for crying. It is what your body
does naturally. The higher the tension
the higher the release. If you were
going to say anything
then you're going to label the tears.
You're going to say these are tired
tears. These are tears that care.
These are are tears that are frustrated.
You label them. It is it is your stress
in liquid form. And that's all it is and
it's nothing to be ashamed of. Now, if
somebody is, let's say,
on the other side of it and you're
talking to them and they start to cry.
What you don't do is go, "Oh, Jesus,
again."
Oh, great. Oh, well, let me guess,
you're going to cry. Now, you're going
to cry. Yeah, okay. They're crying now.
Like, that is the worst because you're
saying you're not a safe place.
If what I don't want somebody crying to
do is say, "I'm sorry." Don't don't
apologize and say, "I'm so sorry I'm
crying."
Take that, throw it away. Don't ever say
that again. There's nothing to apologize
for what your body does. If somebody
else is crying, you're not going to
apologize for them crying, either.
Understand that that is their body doing
what their body needs to do because it
is a stressful situation.
If you need to If you need to, you can
get a tissue
and put it down. Don't feel like you
need to put it in their face and go,
"Okay, fine. You
You good? Get it all out. Oh, great.
Okay, I guess we'll just wait."
Anytime you do that, it's just eroding
the trust. You need to just continue to
talk to them as if they're not.
Because it serves as as a distraction,
otherwise. And it eliminates that idea
of somebody using tears to manipulate,
too. So, it's a a good way of just
continuing to talk to them. Keep
talking. Keep talking. Acting like
they're not crying.
>> Really?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> What if they need a moment when they're
really like having their last
difference? You say, "Hey, we can we can
pause for a moment if you just want to
>> Absolutely. There's nothing wrong with
saying, "Hey, you need You want to take
a time out?"
>> Yeah.
>> Nothing wrong with that. But it's the
when you act exasperated, if you roll
your eyes and
take a big sigh, that's where you that's
where you eroding the trust. You need to
be a safe space for that. If the If
you're just saying it's it's not
bothering you. So, if you can just say,
"I'm still here. Keep going."
Like, you're good. Keep going. Like,
that that's typically If you can just
say keep going, it is saying, "Hey,
don't worry about that."
>> Keep going. Yeah.
>> Yeah. And don't don't ever act
exasperated.
>> Sure.
>> That's bad way to do it.
>> I would love for all those people at
home who are either in partnerships or
friendships where arguing happens.
>> Yeah.
>> Jefferson Fisher, uh
you and your wife being attorneys, being
phenomenal communicators, right? Having
sometimes your job depending on it.
>> Mhm.
>> Um and then you, of course, becoming now
one of the most well-known communicators
in the world. Um tens of millions of
people going to you for this. Uh how do
you and your wife argue?
And like, let us in on all the secrets
that we all need to be doing
differently.
>> Are you ready for the tea? Okay, my wife
No, I'm kidding. Um
She's a fantastic communicator. Law
really teaches you to be concise. And
what I like to compare it is I'm a lot
slower. She operates a lot faster. But
often we have to communicate the same
level. When you have two kids and you're
raising a family and everything, it's
it's a lot.
Our arguments are very short. And the
reason because of that is we
operate on this
very quick to apologize, very quick to
resolve. If you want your argument to be
shorter with your spouse, with your
partner, with your friend, be quick to
apologize.
>> Mhm.
>> So often it is the continual
circular arguments that just tend to
roll on forever cuz you can't really
sleep. When you're having that bad
argument with your spouse or a
significant other, it keeps you up at
night.
>> Mhm.
>> It begins to live and seep, and now
you're having to put on an act for your
kids
>> Mhm.
>> when really you're irritated at each
other and you want to lash out.
>> Mhm.
>> Being quick to apologize and quick to
resolve,
that makes our arguments very short
because
we're fast to say, "That's not what I
meant." Or, you know, I I I can see how
that's how you would take it. I didn't I
didn't mean it that way. I didn't intend
it that way. Whenever you can push out
your intentions rather than pushing
how they should react,
that's a big difference. What I mean by
that is here I am taking the
accountability of I could have done
better communicating that
versus why would you behave that way?
Why would you even behave that way when
I said this? Who reacts
So, when you when you take the
responsibility for being understood,
radical things can change.
>> Even if you think they're completely at
fault, they don't get it, they should do
different, they should do better, but
that's going to go to for an argument
forever cuz I've tried that.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you're saying that you're not saying
they're right by apologizing or by, you
know, you're saying, "Oh, wait, maybe I
could have communicated that
differently."
>> Right.
>> your part to try to make the argument
shorter.
>> There are times when
and again, I'm not pointing to where the
people are in toxic relationships. You
have people with narcissistic
tendencies. Yes, that can be circular
and terrible. I'm not saying you should
just apologize to apologize.
>> Yeah.
>> What I'm communicating is
whenever there is a friction in the
conversation,
>> Yeah.
>> we make sure that it doesn't get heated.
In other words, it doesn't combust and
turn into flame. It is trying to draw it
out by unraveling the knot and going,
"Okay,
this is how I
understood it. What What did you hear?
Okay, that's what All right, that's not
what I intended at all. I'm sorry. What
I meant to say was X, Y, and Z." So, the
quicker you can get to that, the better.
>> That's so good. Okay, so this is what I
intended, what did you hear?
>> Yes.
>> And then, "Oh, okay, well, that's not
what I intended. Here's this."
>> Right.
>> You know,
I want to just share something that I
think is so is so profound because every
time I was growing up, when I knew my
parents were arguing or this or that,
you know, they didn't argue much. My
parents actually just didn't talk about
hard things. When they did argue and I
knew I knew that they were I would go in
and and I would, you know, say is
everything okay? And they're like,
"Absolutely." And you know, they cover
it up and we think we want to protect
our kids and and and hide it. But if the
argument's getting dragged out
and we're actually hiding it, uh you
know, I read something where children
are learning to not trust their own
intuition cuz they're saying is
everything okay? And we're like, "Oh,
it's fine. It's fine." They know it's
not. Yeah, they can sense it. They sense
it and we're saying don't trust your
senses or your senses are off or
something like that. And so the idea of,
you know, the stronger you become at
communicating and learning how to
respond in an argument with someone you
love in a way that diffuses it um just
has so many ripple effects beyond just
that particular thing. So I love that.
Um
>> I want to make sure I tell you
right along with that
um this happened
sometime la- last year with my son
um who's now seven.
And
I got home, long day, suit and tie
and I am starting to make their lunches
for tomorrow.
Son asked me, you know,
"How your day was, Dad?"
And I said, "It was fine, buddy. It was
good. It was It was good It was good
day." And how was your day? And I'm
continuing to make the sandwich.
And he doesn't bring it up again. We go
on about dinner and bedtime, bath,
everything. I am sitting on his bed for
prayers and song.
And
first thing he asked was, "Why'd you
tell me it was a good day when it
wasn't?"
I kid you not. That is exactly what he
said. I so I said I said, "What did you
mean?" He said, "You didn't say it like
it was good. You said it like you were
sad." And I mean I it was
such a just slap in the face of
I'm never going to say it was just good
again. I need to He needs to hear that
from me even when the day's been bad. He
needs to hear when it's been tough. I
mean, that that's
And it was just this moment of how dare
I try to just gloss over the fact of
that he needs to know that I have hard
days, too.
And that hit me just like a ton of
bricks.
Um
So, yeah, no no hiding from him. Yeah.
>> Wow. Um you know, you say I think this
is something really really powerful
because a lot of people don't They don't
want to get in an argument. A lot of
people don't even want to have a
conversation, especially if there's like
anything hard or difficult or
challenging or
you know, any of it. And you say um that
when you align your conversations
um or your arguments with your personal
values, that you're sort of aligned then
ahead of time with your goals before you
go into it. Can you explain to us what
that means and how we all do it right
now today in our lives?
>> So, values are intrinsic to everybody.
What are our values going to be
different than what you value? They
might be similar, but we all take it
different ways based on how we've been
raised.
What values do is guide you like a a
North Star when there's you don't have
any kind of compass.
What I do when I encourage is that
people have conversational
values because when you do, decisions
become easier. Take it for example with
a company. Your major Fortune 500
companies
like your company. There are ones that
have values, and when you have a value,
decisions become easier because you
don't have to question it. You follow
the value. If my value is I only work
with clients who align with me,
comes easy. I don't have to make that
decision. I know that that's who I'm
going to work with. Same thing in your
conversation. So, one of my
uh values that I hold dearly is where
there is kindness, I will use it.
Or where there is room for kindness, I
will use it. Doesn't matter what they
did. Doesn't matter what they caused.
The question is, is there room for
kindness? And that comes from my mama.
I'd complain about something that
someone happened at school expecting her
to, you know,
buy into the tea. Let's Let's get some,
you know, how dare they kind of thing.
And what my mom would say is, "Well,
were you kind?"
I can hear it in my head. She'd say,
"Well, well, were you kind?"
And I would always go,
uh
I mean, I probably not, Mom. And she'd
go, "Well, I think you should be kind."
I mean, that was just her thing.
And that became my such of value of me
of when I'm talking on the phone to an
opposing attorney and he says something
snide, I know that he's trying to jab
me. Is there room for kindness?
I'll use it.
And I'll say something like, "Well, you
know what? I I know you really care for
your clients. I know you really care for
your clients, Matt, and that and that
really shows. Anyway that I can just
share a little bit of kindness, I don't
have to worry about the next zinger. I
don't have to worry about what can I say
to impress him. Is there room for
kindness?" And that's what I'll do. But
I have I have others.
>> like that works to your advantage even
with
a snide attorney on the call?
>> Yes, because the
>> They don't mistake it for weakness.
>> Because how they interpret it is going
to be how they interpret it. I'm the one
that has to be left with it. I'm the one
that has to to walk away and go home to
my family and if I'm carrying that
conversation that I had with that
opposing attorney home,
why?
It's they they don't deserve that.
That's not what that conversation was
for. That's not why they said it. Um and
so the having these values, another that
I I love to use is if I can't be a
bridge, be a lighthouse.
If things burn down and don't work out
with that other people, that's okay.
They'll always tell me where I'm at.
They'll They always know where to find
me. So, when you have these ideas in
your head of what my value is,
>> Explain that a little bit more. If I
can't be a bridge.
>> Be a lighthouse.
>> lighthouse.
>> Yeah, so
let's say you and I um
been friends and we have a big fall out.
Despite what I say and I I'm really
trying to mend this relationship um and
it's just not happening. They've you've
written me off. It's not working out.
That bridge is really burned.
Well, that's okay. I'm still going to be
a lighthouse. Maybe I'll see you in 5
years. Maybe I see you in 15 years when
life has happened to both of us.
>> Mhm.
>> But I'm not going to change the light
that I'm going to
to put out into the world just because
of our bridge was burned.
>> Or the light you wish that other person.
>> Yes. Yeah, absolutely. And so when you
have these values and every one of us
has a value and you you that's how you
handle your conversations
because it allows you to I don't have to
worry about decisions.
The values make the decisions for me.
>> Mhm. That's so good. I love that too
because I've had to do this. I wish I've
never had to do this. I had to do this
even recently where a friend just
uh
just like completely wasn't the friend I
thought they were. And I think parts of
our humanness want to you know tell them
all the reasons they're wrong or this or
that or all the things and it's like I
think when you can just be a lighthouse
and go okay, so it's a different
friendship than I thought.
>> Yeah.
>> And I'm just going to
pray for them and love on them and I
feel like what happens then is you meet
the vibration also of attracting great
friends.
>> Yes.
>> when you when you
>> your gift.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> that's where it comes back. Whenever you
send that zinger, that clap back, that
sense of oof man, I just put together
the perfect paragraph that's going to
punch them in the mouth.
>> Yeah.
>> It's got it always has a bad aftertaste.
>> Always.
>> Yeah.
>> It may not be right within that moment.
It but it'll probably be the next
morning.
>> Mhm.
>> It'll definitely be a week from now. And
I mean it's
the longer it goes, the harder it is to
come back together.
>> Mhm.
I even think about that when I see
comments online. Someone just like
>> Oh, yeah.
>> You know, it it can feel like a
temporary relief or something when you
just, you know, get that hateful comment
out or talk someone down. But then
you're meeting the vibration of that in
your life. So, it just comes all around
you in different in different areas. So,
that's so beautiful. Be the lighthouse.
>> Yeah.
>> Even if you're not
>> Even if you're not the bridge. Even if
you're not the bridge.
>> How and what role What role does
self-worth play in communication with
others and with ourself?
>> Self-worth matters of who you're
listening to.
It's the question of who are you
listening to when it's
Say I have the confidence or I can be
assertive or
I shouldn't have said that. It is the
line of who who are you listening to in
your life that's driving your
your own value. So much of what we put
in self-value
uh is a lie. Often, it's doubt.
We we sow a lot of doubt into ourselves
and that can grow over time to where
when you get that one comment from a
troll, all of a sudden you feel like
they're telling you the truth.
>> Mhm.
>> When really all they're doing is
speaking to your doubts.
>> Mhm.
>> And self-worth is a something that you
can grow into and
I don't want to say lean into. It's
something you can step into.
>> Mhm.
>> Because when you can learn how to
communicate effectively to stand up for
yourself,
>> Mhm.
>> just a little bit, you have that
self-worth. When you can tell somebody
no and it works,
>> Mhm.
>> you feel excited about it. You feel
worthy. You feel like, "Hey, I have that
within myself." A good good job. Okay,
now you feel a little bit better and
then you continue to grow in that step
by step by step. But self-worth is very
much tied to your communication because
again, how you communicate
is who you are and how you feel about
yourself.
>> And how you communicate with yourself,
right?
>> Oh, yeah. Yes, I no doubt. And because
it's
Remember who who are you listening to?
Am I listening to my own doubts? Be
people who are negative
say negative things.
And people who are positive say positive
things. I It's as as simple as that.
When you start to doubt yourself, it's
cuz you're you're listening to your
doubts. You're not listening to the
positivity. When you feel anxious,
you're listening to the anxiety-inducing
thoughts of what ifs of what ifs rather
than
the the comfort in knowing I knows I
knows I knows.
>> These are such powerful tools that we
can apply to our life right now.
>> Right.
>> Like and what I love is they're free.
They're free
and they're not always easy, but we can
get in the habit of them. We can apply
them right now.
>> Well, I think what happens in
conversations and arguments, like when
you're trying to
you know, raise your point to somebody
or you disagree
is in order for you to feel like
validated, I think
it has to come from the other person,
right? People are like, "I'm not going
to feel better until that person like
gets me." Like how can people I got to
say you and I are having a conversation
and
I'm telling you like I didn't like the
way that you treated me or spoke to me
like last week when we were when we were
out or when we were at some event or
something. And you're like, you know,
I see things differently. And I'm like,
"Well," and I'm trying to keep hammering
home the point. Like how could I get to
a place
where I feel like my my point is known
to you without you being like, "You're
right."
>> So, use the phrase I can see. Begin your
sentence with I can see.
I can see how it can make you feel that
way.
I can see how that would impact you. I
can see how that would upset you.
And when you say that, you you are
automatically acknowledging that hey,
what you're saying is it's an accurate
It's it's an accurate description
from your point of view. I can see that.
Well, instead of just going, "That's not
true. That's not That's not what I said.
That's so I like That's That didn't
happen."
You're never going to get them to your
side of the the court that way. But when
you can begin with I can see that. I can
see how you'd say that.
It's it's it's better than I understand
or I get it. Because
one says I see things from your view.
I'm going over to where you are standing
in your shoes and looking at what you're
looking at. The other says, I understand
the point that you're making.
Very different. One says, I have been
there with you and I'm looking at it
your way. I can see how you'd feel that
way.
And it feels like you're justified like
it's they're justified. They're
acknowledged. They they feel heard and
they're stood and ooh, it's going to
calm them down. They're not going to be
nearly as offensive. One thing that I'll
also like to teach is when
like there's a disagreement over what
you said, No, that's not what I said. If
you ask the other person ins- instead of
saying that's not what I said, you ask
the question, what did you hear?
And that that opens it up to their
perspective because
I can say something
and somebody can regurgitate it back and
you go, what planet are we on? Were we
in the same room when this happened?
Like that's not what I said at all.
That's not how I said that. What are you
What are you talking about? Like say a
relationship with a spouse. Like
somebody might The other spouse might
go, yeah, you you know, you just said
"Meow meow meow." And they like try to
imitate you in a very sarcastic tone and
you're like, That's That's not what I
said at all.
It's because you are only trying to push
what you've said rather than giving
attention to what they heard. Cuz what
they'll hear is almost always very
different.
>> And sometimes in relationships,
what happens is patterns can kind of
happen and you know, people make
mistakes and they say things they don't
necessarily mean and then that tends to
bother the other person. Like, how can
somebody bring up
like something that's bothering them in
a relationship that allows them to
feel heard, get their point across, but
can like
help protect themselves from that other
person getting defensive.
>> Anytime you're having to have a
difficult conversation like this, I like
to teach about frames.
So, this is in my rule number three, say
it to connect, and we talk about frames
in the book. And it lays out how to have
a difficult conversation, almost like a
formula that works for any really any
topic. Number one, you tell them what
you want to talk about. Two, you tell
them how you want to feel after that
conversation. And three, you get their
buy-in into that frame. So, let's say
in your scenario, you need to bring up
something that bothers you.
Uh so, we could say from the beginning,
instead of all this fluff, like let's
let's do real quick how it could go
wrong. If you go, "Hey, so remember when
you did X and like we said this and and
the other person's going, "Where you
going? What are you talking about?
What's what's happening here?" And the
anxiety builds, the defensiveness
builds, and you're you're like, "Can you
just get to the point, please?"
And all they're feeling is you're
dismissing, you're not caring, you don't
want to talk about this, which they
feel, they sense, it spirals down from
there. Instead of all the fluff, me
getting with that small talk, if you
begin with, "I like to talk about
something I like to talk with you about
something that bothers me or that's been
bothering me." That's one. So, you got
you got their attention.
You're not waiting till the very end to
tell them that it bothers you. Two,
"And I don't want you to try and fix it.
I just want to feel heard on this."
That's number two, you're telling them
how you want the conversation to end.
So, it could be as simple as, "I'm not
asking you to fix this.
I'm not asking for us to do anything
with it. I just need to voice it for me
to process it." You see how it's a much
better like now I know what you're
wanting. Now I'm not trying to step in
and fix it every single way. Last part
three is getting their buy-in to the
frame. That's as easy as saying, "Does
that sound good? Can we do that? Is that
all right?" And they will say yes. I
mean, they're going to say yes, and once
they do, you kind of have this invisible
contract of now we know what to talk
about. Now we know we're going to be
talking about something that they know
bothers you.
Two, they know they don't need to fix
it. They're not trying to solve
anything. You just want to be heard. Or
it could it maybe you want to say, "And
I want to say this and explain this so
we have we can talk about some steps to
where I'm not going to feel this way or
this isn't going to happen again." I
mean, that's where you're actually
having a goal for the conversation. That
Now they know where you're going in the
conversation, and it's going to improve
it every time.
>> And what about like you have the right
frame like you just said, you talk about
something that's bothering you, and then
it happens again, which is normal, I
think, in a relationship. People aren't
perfect. You don't People don't change
overnight. How can you bring that up in
a way that is healthy? Cuz I think what
tends to happen is people are like, "I
told you about this. You said you would
do this." Or "Why aren't you changing?
You're not listening to me. You're not
hearing me." Like how can people convey
that without people shutting down?
>> Well, as soon as you start throwing the
the yous,
"You always do this. You never listen.
You always" and you just it's going to
mat automatically put up the spikes, put
up the
the moat and the drawbridge, and forget
about it.
I would say just using another frame.
You're just going to tweak how you begin
it. So, if it's I like to talk to you
about some repeated behavior that's
really concerning to me.
I like to talk about a pattern that I'm
seeing that
it frankly scares me,
and I want to talk about it because I
want to walk away from this conversation
feeling like there's going to be some
change because if there's not,
that that causes a problem.
Is Can we talk about that? Like that's a
much healthier way
to discuss it cuz you're telling them,
"I'm seeing a pattern.
It's important to me.
And the reason why it's important to me
is because it is going to be
determinative of
where we are in the future." When it
comes to handling conflict, which is
what we're we're talking about now.
We're talking about having difficult
conversations. We've talked about like
defensiveness and stuff.
Do you think there's any way to I don't
want to say prevent conflict, cuz
conflicts going to happen in life, but
to mitigate it specifically like in
relationships. Like do you propose like
scheduling time to connect about things
that are bothering you, or do you just
propose like waiting until something
happens? I feel comfortable first with
the
idea that conflict should be welcomed.
I don't mean that in a negative way. I
mean good conflict.
Everything of how you got to where you
are in life is because some sort of
conflict.
Uh you broke up with that one spouse or
one, you know, relationship that has led
you to the next one. You left one job
because you found another one. The whole
way we are in our our laws
and the legal system and everything
become out of conflict. Case law in my
world, like how we have case law comes
from facts of cases that happened that
were conflicts that generated the law.
So, conflict is a can be very much a
stimu- stimulus for good. Say, "Okay, do
you want conflict in relationships? How
do you minimize that?"
Well, I understand let's start with the
premise that conflict can be inherently
good because if you want
deeper relationships, then you have to
have a deep intolerance for difficult
conversations.
If you've only had surface level
conversations with somebody, well, I'll
show you a surface level relationship.
You need to have the deep ones, the ones
that have been
you really get to go deep with somebody
because that's how you get to know them.
When you come out on the other side of
something very difficult, bonds are
made. You feel stronger. You feel like
you know the real person. It's like in
the military when they have to go
through elements of just war and combat.
I mean, they come out on the other side
inseparable. It is you have to go
through the difficult. So, there has to
be number one, a willingness
to see conflict as not as a zero-sum
game, but as something that we can work
through together. Two is not sweating
the small stuff.
If you want to have a fight over every
little thing, and by the way, in
relationships, I feel like most fights
are about the small stuff. Like the
worst fights happen over the dumbest
little things, and it just happened to
be at the the wrong time
where you decide to have this
conversation. When you're tired, they're
tired, somebody hasn't eaten, so you're
a little bit grumpy, and you're like,
"You know what? Let's go. Let's Let's
just have this out right now. Come on,
you want to talk?" And it's just it's
not going to go well because we
we sweat over the the little things.
And three is it's okay to have conflict.
It's It can be a healthy thing. Hard to
minimize it because we're natural
people, and it's just for normal.
It is understanding of where it's going
to go.
If you know the goal of the
conversation, rather than again, what we
said, win, lose,
and you just see that as let's talk
about this in perspectives, it's
informing you about the data behind the
other person. So, see it as a as a
a vessel for good in your life.
>> What's the most effective way to to not
sweat the small stuff? Something that's
so difficult to do.
>> You have to have this mindset of
grace. This mindset of giving benefits
of the doubt.
You know, that they they mean it
personally, that they don't want to ruin
your life, that inherently people
want to be good and kind and understood.
Even when somebody is yelling at you,
you see it as a threat
to their nervous system that they're
experiencing in that moment, that
something is threatening their nervous
system. You have to get curious enough
to find out what is triggering in this
moment. We talked about that having a
conversation that you were invited to.
That happens with everybody. When they
escalate, maybe you're in a meeting and
all of a sudden there's a guy who just
puffs up and gets so mad. It's really
the insecurity, the little person who's
always had the chip on the shoulder,
that's yelling right in that moment. So
often
it is just the hearing of their tone in
their voice are bids for connection,
that they want to be understood. They
just don't know how to voice it. How do
you sweat How do you not sweat the small
stuff?
You give a lot of grace in the
conversation and understanding. What are
you going to make? My dad would say,
"Don't make that your Alamo." Like here
in Texas history, you know, is that
going to be the the hill that you die
on? Is that really
Is that really going to be the most
important thing to you right now?
Usually, if you ask that question, like
is this really that important to you?
Most often it's not. Are you going to
move the couch 2 in?
Uh I mean, is that really going to be
what you're going to
put your flag in the ground on?
So it's it's more of a relationship and
conversation with yourself rather than
the other person when it comes to the
small stuff. And as any new debut
author,
I, for good or for bad, have been
looking at reviews online. Cuz you want
to know are are people going to like the
book? That's the whole You get very
nervous. Are Are Are you going to
deliver on the message?
And the reviews have been so kind and
wonderful. And there was one that hit me
yesterday that I randomly saw
that I wanted to share with you. It's
very short. I know you can listen to it.
Just bear with me. I know you can do it.
Listen.
You are not a target.
I was once told by my husband, "You are
an easy target and everyone knows it."
Time and again, I walked away defeated
even with my children. Jefferson showed
me what I lacked was communication
skills.
From his social media, I started
applying these answers to difficult
situations.
Let me be clear. This is not a book of
his social media quips. That's what I
thought it would be. No. It is learning
to understand where people are and to
adequately communicate with them. It's
teaching to deepen relationships by way
of strong communication skills. You are
not a weak person for purchasing this
book.
You are strong and courageous for
recognizing there is a better way to
bridge a gap, create healthy boundaries
that work, to not get sucked down a
rabbit hole, to not think you've lost
your mind.
I highly recommend and I'm starting my
second read through. Kindle edition is
an easy read. Bless you, Jefferson, for
exhibiting love for people.
I I was just taken aback. I was totally
blown away by this.
I've no clue who this person is. In
fact, they didn't even leave their name.
It just says verified purchaser.
This is my point with this is I want you
to know where to go
in your mind
when conflict comes your way. You are
not a target.
And if you felt like you've been your
whole life, this is where it stops.
Rule number one in my book, there are
three rules. It's rule number one, say
it with control. Number two, say it with
confidence. Number three, say it to
connect.
And the whole focus of rule number one
is you can't say anything about what I
teach you, whether it's my phrases, my
quips, my little words, everything that
I I I can give you. None of it matters
if you do not say it
with control. If you do not first
regulate yourself.
So, we're going to talk about in this
episode what I want you to think about
when conflict comes your way.
Anytime that somebody says something
that you weren't expecting
your body naturally through its biology
reacts.
People think that fight or flight is
something that has to happen when you
come with physical contact. No.
That's not true.
It happens every day in these little
micro moments. Even when somebody just
flatly disagrees with you. When somebody
disagrees with your opinion or they say
something you don't like or they call
you an ugly name, your body goes, "Hey
brain, I I didn't like that." And the
brain goes, "Give me a second. Yeah, no.
We definitely didn't like that." And it
naturally reacts. You have a scowl on
your face. You want to say something
back. You get heated. Your neck and jaw
get tense. All biological. All normal.
All natural. So, what do you do with
that?
Rule number one in my book is you use
your breath
as the first word that you say. And the
reason why is because it adds a distance
between what they say
and how you respond, which gives you
time to regulate yourself, to think of
the quips that I give you and the
sentences I give you. And it also mutual
The other benefit is it allows the other
person
to calm down theirs as well. Gives time
for that analytical side to take over.
Every day there are little things that
tell your body, "I am threatened."
Somebody cuts in front of you in
traffic. Somebody merges. Somebody's
riding on your bumper. Your body goes,
"I am threatened." That's where road
rage comes from.
I feel threatened in this environment.
When you're talking with your kids, when
somebody um says something to you that
they disagree with your opinion, they
dismiss your idea. You don't like that.
Your body's saying, "Hey, that feels
threatening to me. I want you to do
something for me right now. Now, if
you're driving, don't worry about it. If
you're walking on the treadmill, don't
worry about it. You can do it later, do
it in your head with me right now. I
want you to think of
behavior that somebody does that really
really upsets you. And we're going to
put a label on it. For example, maybe
it's disrespect,
dismissive,
condescending,
belittling,
rude. Whatever it is, make it yours.
What is a behavior that somebody
exhibits that really just just feels
like it sets you off, that just you just
explode when somebody does this to you.
You got it? You find that word.
Now,
write it down.
And right next to it, I want you to
write does not threaten me.
Does not threaten me.
So, the sentence would be
Dismissiveness does not threaten me.
Root comments, back talk,
insults do not threaten me.
This is the mindset I want you to have
when this kind of stuff comes up in your
life. Why? Because it is telling your
body of hey, when somebody raises their
voice, that doesn't threaten me.
When somebody calls me that, the way I'm
reacting and telling my body is
hey, this does not threaten me.
That's what you're doing with your
breath in that moment. That's why we
give it time to tell your body what is
happening in front of me is not a
threat.
Right? It's this idea that
um you have you've seen the big animals
whether it's a lion or an elephant or
something they have like some
maybe a little dog or something it they
just go what is this? It's like a little
animal coming up to a big animal.
They're not threatened in any way.
That's the whole mindset here of hey,
what you're doing is this isn't
threatening to me. I'm seeing right
through it. Cool?
I'm going to tell you a quick story
right now that
um I haven't I don't think I've ever
shared.
This was I don't know, maybe 3 weeks ago
or so.
And
where was I? I might have I think it was
in San Diego Airport. I was in the San
Diego Airport. It may have been San
Diego. Everything's
blurring blending together at this
moment and it's early. Give me a break.
Is
I got through security at TSA
and went and I was looking for my gate.
Looking for my gate and I kept following
the signs and then all of a sudden I was
outside of it outside of the the
security. The gate, the terminal, it
wasn't the terminal. The gate was
actually in a separate terminal and I
just walked myself all the way through.
I had already gone through security. I
had already gone through all the the
check and the getting your stuff out and
ready and giving your ID.
I had to I started walking out and I
passed this exit where it goes, you
know, the point of no return
or has a red line there at the airport.
And I walk out of it
and all of a sudden this is me by myself
and I look and I go I say this out loud.
I go, "Oh my gosh, I got to
do this all over again."
Because I have to know I'm going further
down
where a separate terminal is.
And I said, "Oh my gosh, I I got to do
this all over again." And a voice that
I had no clue where it was coming from.
Female voice goes
"That's why you should read the signs,
sir."
And I'm trying to find who
that is and I turn and look
and as I'm looking she goes, "You have
no one to blame but yourself, sir.
That's why we have signs."
I don't know if you're feeling this just
hearing it to me. Just the way
the tone came across
was so condescending and unexpected and
unnecessary. You ever had that?
That's why we have signs, sir. You have
no one to blame but yourself.
And I remember
being just taken aback. Uh who who who
are you? And it was a TSA agent. Now, if
you're a TSA agent, I know not everybody
is
rough and can be terrible. And hey, I'm
an attorney, for crying out loud. Not
all attorneys are bad. There are some
TSA agents that are wonderful. There are
some people that are bad. We all have
bad apples in every profession. This one
right here,
this lady, she was middle-aged lady,
uh just looked so smug when she when she
said that.
And this is what my my body wanted
to come back with some really good
zingers in that moment. I wanted to say
a few things to her because it was
really rude. It was kind of It was
unnecessary.
And this is what I did. Of course, I
have to practice what I preach, right?
I gave it I looked at her for like 5
seconds
trying to figure out
is this
Did she say that?
And I just give it time.
And now she's sitting back and blinking
and looking at me. Her smile is gone.
And this is what I asked her. I said,
"How do you feel
when you say that kind of thing to
someone?
Does it give you joy?"
That's what I said. Like verbatim.
And immediately
she got red. Like um uh and just got red
in the face
and apologized right there.
I didn't have to prompt anything. She
was I'm I'm sorry I'm sorry, sir. You're
you're right. I that wasn't kind. You're
you're right, sir. I'm I'm sorry. Yes,
you you you can find the terminal if you
go straight down and now she was in
helping mode. Now she was in helping
mode. You can go right here and this is
where it's going to be. I would say,
"Oh, well, thank you very much. I
appreciate that. All right. You have a
wonderful day."
You are not a target.
You are not somebody's punching bag. You
are not the outlet for somebody to
release all of their frustrations and
their angers and their smugness
on you.
These tools work. This is why I talk
about at them. That's why I feel so
passionate about sharing these.
You had the choice right in that moment
when somebody says something ugly, when
they're the TSA agent in your life,
how are you going to react? What are you
going to say to that person?
Are you going to allow them to just
press your remote control, manipulate
all your emotions? I had a choice. You
have a choice. Is that going to ruin
your day? I just can't believe you'd say
that. Excuse me, is that what Excuse me,
are you talking to me?
You see how it easily could go the other
way when you give in to that fight or
flight, when you don't use your breath,
when you don't regulate yourself.
If you do not say things with control,
it doesn't matter
what kind of tip I can give you. It's
not going to work. It ain't going to
work.
You have to say it with control.
You are not
a target.
I hope that
this is a good reminder for you,
wherever you are.
I can give you lots of tools and tips on
what to say
and we have different podcast episodes
on that and I'm going to continue to
give you podcast episodes on this.
And I want to make sure that you know
and you hear and really the message is
very simple for today.
You are not a target.
When that happens, I want you to go to
your breath,
regulate yourself,
and then use the questions that I've
taught you. These are questions like,
"Did you mean Did you mean for that to
be rude?
Did you mean to insult me? Did you mean
for that to embarrass me?"
Or you give it time, and then you ask
somebody a question of intent. "How did
you expect me to react to that?" I could
have said that to her.
"How did you want me to respond to
that?"
"How does it make you feel?"
Imagine being the person
who would say that to someone.
These These ways of responding to rude
behavior
that is actually not a response. It's a
question.
You're not giving them matters of
substance. I'm not saying, "Let me You
You spit in my eye, let me spit back in
yours."
No, it is a reflection of their own
behavior and character.
And nine times out of 10, the other
person sees that because they because
you're giving them time to are seeing
It's like uh the the blood the the red
Uh it's not blood. The red comes out of
their
system. You know, where somebody's
seeing red, you have to give them time
for that to
go away.
Come back to normal. Come back. I know
that's not who you are. People are not
People are
far better
than we give them a chance to be. Why?
Because we know that in ourselves. So,
when you have the patience and the
discipline to get to that, you're going
to have a better communication and a
better relationship and a better life
because of that.
>> Lots of questions going through my mind
of what I want to ask you next. Um
you have a very calming demeanor, by the
way. I mean, we just we just met, you
know, 10 minutes ago, 15 minutes ago.
And I I came on to the recording. I was
like super frazzled, was a couple
minutes late. And just the first few
words out of your mouth, I was like,
"Oh, he's a calm presence." He has like
a very soothing voice and
felt my, you know, felt my frustration
and anxiety decrease a little bit just
with that. Is that intentional? Like,
have you intentionally
learned
how to present yourself and how to show
up in a certain way
um in order to just deflate a situation?
>> The answer is
that comes naturally from what I have
what's been modeled for me.
>> Mhm.
>> I I I have I will absolutely say that I
have been blessed in a way to see
models of diplomacy
in my family and how they handle and
address conflict. I'd grow up, I'd get
so mad I mean, I'm a teenager. I'm
getting mad at my mom. She's trying to
control me. She's trying to do this. And
I'd come to dad and dad'd go, "So?"
You know, like, "But But dad, I got this
this this. You don't understand." He'd
go,
"So?"
You know, I mean, and it would be like,
"Man, but yeah, he's he's he's right."
And so, his whole thing was,
you know, "Hey,
don't make that your Alamo. In other
words, don't Is that the hill you're
going to die on? Really?"
And he was just so good at like
deconstructing
a lot of the ways I would I would feel
that. And it became very natural to me
in my demeanor to slow down.
And as an attorney, especially, I very
much honed that behavior because my sole
job is to
send my clients into just
intense conflict. So, I have to train
them and teach them and calm them down
in in very
um significant ways.
And a part of that is what I've learned
now, now that I've like working
backwards of why why is that.
Um
that
my lower voice or using a calming voice,
a slower register, which comes very
natural to me,
actually makes other people's
um their their sympathetic nervous
system like it matches their energy and
the frequency to calm them down. So,
they often times it would be different
if I came on and I just started yelling
or I was really intense, you're going to
also feel that intensity. So, we tend to
mirror each other. And so, when I come
in, I'm a lot more calming and talking
about our day and how's your morning
going,
then your body's like, "Oh, I like Okay,
I can match this frequency." And then it
kind of just starts to
ease.
>> To ease in, to ease down, that's for
sure.
>> Yeah.
>> Let's talk about the the person who is
angry, wants justice, believes they're
right, wants their way.
>> Yeah.
>> You probably deal with some of these
people.
>> Every day.
>> Every every day.
Uh
what is your What have you seen work?
How do you get people to shift their
mindset and shift their behaviors so
that the other person can actually hear
what they're trying to say?
>> Mhm.
So, let's put it in a context. Let's say
um
let's let's put it I assume for your
readers
it's marriage, it's relationship.
>> Mhm.
>> Let's put it Let's put it uh
contextually. They they come into the
kitchen, what's what's happening?
>> Yeah. Okay, they come into the kitchen
and let's say they're it's a let's say
it's a wife. She's been working hard all
day getting the house clean, making
dinner, and for the fifth night in a row
her husband is not home on time for
dinner like he said he was going to be.
And it's not just the fact that he's not
home. Uh it's he doesn't respect me, he
doesn't love me, this isn't right.
>> Right.
>> And so, he comes in and he doesn't see
what the big deal is. And she's upset
and feels
disrespected and unloved. And what she
says to him is,
"Why are you never home? Why don't you
want to be with me? You need to change.
Like, we have to start spending more
time together." So on and so forth.
>> Mhm.
That's hard.
>> And let's let's make it even harder.
Let's say kids are around.
>> Yeah, let's absolutely. They're sitting
at the dinner table.
>> Yeah, let's let's let's Yeah, let's make
it more let's make it even harder. Kids
are sitting at the dinner table. They're
already finishing dinner.
And husband comes in late.
>> Mhm.
>> So, mom has a choice at that moment.
Do I
do I address this now, or do I address
this later? Now, that
I think the first part of it is is
personal preference.
I would recommend
that it is not addressed in front of the
kids. That's just my that's my personal
belief. I grew up in a household that if
you wanted to have a significant argue,
you know, conversation, even if it was
an argument,
it needs to be done away from child's
ears, because they don't they don't
understand the context.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, and I don't
I don't believe that kind of behavior,
should it turn ugly, should be modeled
in
in front of kids, if you if you can't
have it in a healthy way. But, it sounds
like under our scenario, it's not going
to be had in a in a very healthy
healthy way.
So,
dinner goes exactly as it should.
You can either choose to address say,
you know,
"Hi, dad's here. Let's finish dinner.
Let's have bed." Let them have a good
night's sleep. Let them have a good
night's rest.
Then you turn to address the
conversation in in the room. What you
don't want to do is start off with a
why.
Like, put pushing the why question. Yes,
that's the question you want to know,
but when you put it in terms of a why,
very much feels like a challenge. So, it
pushes a threat to our our body of
challenging your autonomy. It challenges
your competence.
If I were to just say to you, Kimberly,
let's say you did something. I said,
"Why'd you do that?"
Our immediate response is, "Because I
wanted to."
>> All right.
>> You know?
>> Who are you to question me?
>> Yeah, yeah. Because that's what I wanted
to do. What's what's it to you?
So, it it
works the same way.
You have times where if you start with
why, it is immediately going to put them
defensive
because it is a challenge. It is a is a
trigger to people. So, the first
question
I My style is very much a a
diplomatic, let's come to the root of
the matter.
>> Mhm.
>> Because if you just start complaining
that they're late, they know that
they're late.
So, you complaining that they're late
does nothing in terms of resolving the
real issue, right?
It's just you venting.
If you need to vent,
tell them that you're going to vent. If
you need to put a frame around it, I
just need to vent to you for a second. I
want to talk about this later.
You know, I want to talk about it
afterwards, but I I
I need to to be a place that that this
vent.
They probably aren't going to want to
hear that. Bigger issue is going to need
to be
um you know,
where's this coming from in terms of the
repeated
behavior.
A very much more powerful way I think
way to address this is, "Do I need to
give up on the idea of you coming home
on time?"
Um because if you ask it that way,
they will answer in the negative.
I've like, "No, no, you don't need to
I can do this. I can do this." At the
same time, you need to be very mindful
of
what's happening in their day as to why
they're late.
And that that means you're asking
questions more along the lines of
um
"What happened today?
How was your day?
Like finding out because because you
really don't know.
>> Right.
>> Most of the time if you just like
typical scenario where I can release
they come home late, kids are down.
Great. So you're just going to be I
guess you're just never going to be
home. Is this what it is? Like you said
you're going to be home the other week.
You have no clue what happened in
his day.
Who Who knows? It could be something
where it's
uh maybe something at work, maybe it was
traffic, maybe it was Who knows?
So you always have to have a pause
understand what's what's really
happening in their world. If it is a
complete sign of disrespect that they
know that they're being late and they
just don't want to be around.
>> Mhm.
>> That's much more of a boundary that you
that you need to put up and be much more
assertive and aggressive with it.
Um that means it sounds more along the
lines of
I'm interested in a relationship that
shows up.
If you're not interested in that and
being with us at dinner, I need to know
that now.
There are times where I think you need
to ask them in ways that
want them to talk to you rather than
want them to close up to you. So often
we feel like the answer is to attack
when that just makes them clam up more.
Rather than trying to be understanding
of what what is it about What is it
about us
that makes you not want to be here?
Uh and that that starts to crack that a
whole lot
more.
>> Mhm.
And it also
I mean the other part of that is
being able and willing to hear what they
might honestly say.
>> Yeah.
>> Because sometimes those answers back
might be Well, then no, there is
something about us that makes me not
want to be here and here it is, right?
And then that can lead to a cycle
of
poor
interaction, poor communication.
>> and
yeah, you'll get in a circle. Yeah, it
is. How many times you get in a in a
it's cyclical where you're getting in an
argument you come to the same place, but
it just gets worse.
>> It just gets worse. And and Jefferson, I
can imagine that, you know, with have
you having a history, a family history,
a professional history, just the
experience in your life, the the
the
What's the word I'm looking for? Like
the importance that you have put on
communication just in general for you,
you probably tend to show up
communicating well in your in your
conversations and in arguments, but
there
are probably people that you get in
arguments with or disagree with and they
don't give the same
kindness back, right? Like they don't
think of not using not saying it in a
challenging way and saying why, right?
So, how do you handle so we can still
continue to use the example of the the
wife who's mad at the husband. So, let's
say the wife is doing all these things.
She's approaching it in the right way,
not asking why, but looking to see what
the core issue is, but he is using all
the wrong communication styles and
blaming her and X, Y, and Z and she's
having to like keep her calm in the
middle of a very difficult conversation.
How would you recommend to continue on
in that conversation when the other
person is difficult to talk to?
>> Oh, yeah. Well, that's
that's just about any argument. They're
going to be difficult to talk to,
especially when you're trying to calm
things down in a way. So, what has been
very beneficial for me
is that I frame my arguments at the
outset.
>> Mhm.
>> Um so, let's say I'm the wife in this
situation.
And I know deep down he's a good dad or
that he really loves us. That's not the
issue. You you know, there's not a fear
of like, are you going around? Do you
not love me? That's That's not the
issue. It's just he's not he's not
coming home when he said he's going to
come home.
>> Mhm.
>> Um
to me, you can frame a conversation by
one acknowledging what you know
and a quality you want them to have. So,
if you and I can really in a
may Let's say you and I are in a
argument
and
I can start at the outset of saying,
"Look,
I know that
being on time is important to you. I
know that attention to detail is
important to you. I know that respect is
important to you. Whatever quality I
want you to have at that time
I want you to show up in
I say it. I speak that over the
conversation.
So, if I am the wife, I say, "Look, I
know that you love us and you love our
children."
And so, you get what I mean? At the
outset, boom, you've you set the tenor
of they are now not going to be feeling
threatened of
I have to show you how much I love you,
but I do this, but I do that. By I mow
the yard, but I I did this. I paid the
bills. I'm working. Like, I I know I
know that you work hard for us and our
family.
Boom, I've already calmed it down.
That's That's you you've hit a fear that
they get have.
Then you frame it. You put it end to the
conversation. Not an Not an end, but you
put a backstop to it.
I want to have a conversation with you,
a real conversation with you
about you coming home late.
And at the end of it, I want to know why
you're not coming home late
and ways that we can think together of
making sure you're home on time.
I want to be a help to that.
Boom, you've now put a backstop on it.
Saying, "Hey, we're going to have this
conversation. Maybe it gets ugly. Maybe
it gets tense, but I've already claimed
at the end of it this is how I want this
to go. Can you agree to that?"
And when you get their buy-in into the
conversation
on the end,
that's always better. So, a lot of times
um you don't have to agree how to get
there. You just have to be aligned on
the goal.
So, if you can get them to buy in on
"Are you willing to engage in a
conversation with me about ways we can
get you here on time?"
They If they're down for that, okay,
then let's then let's talk about it.
What's what's happening?
Uh
you're going to find way more success
than that
in this just throwing darts game.
>> Yeah.
>> Because that's typically we just like to
send zingers.
Things that can hurt. "I'm here with the
kids, you're not. I have this, you're
not." And all you're doing is making
you're hurting them, you're making them
defensive, and you're not at all
addressing the true issue.
>> A key takeaway I took from what you just
said is entering into the conversation
with
a goal.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And how often do people
not?
>> Every time I mean, how many times have
we been in an argument and you think to
yourself
>> Exactly.
>> uh
how did this start? Where where was I
going Where was I going with this? You
go around and then
>> Where am I wanting to end? Even like
what's the point?
>> That too. You go how One, you say, "How
did we even how did we start?" And then
"How do we get out of this argument?"
Like we've just We've lost our way. How
did this even begin? You started talking
about about ironing clothes, and next
thing you know, you're talking about,
you know, something that happened
in 2007
on a a bad date that you had. Like you
just You never know.
Goals Goals, knowing what you want to
the end goal to be before you even start
often cuts down a lot on the fluff.
>> So,
you and your wife, do you just have
super effective communication, clear-cut
arguments that have a goal in mind, like
or does she ever get frustrated that
she's up against someone who's like a
pro at communication? Or do you ever get
frustrated?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Cuz maybe she's better at it than you.
Who knows?
>> Well, she's an attorney, too, actually.
>> Oh my.
>> Yeah, but we've known we've known each
other since we were teenagers.
So,
um knew each other long before we were
attorneys.
>> Yeah.
>> And
all it means in terms of an attorney is
that she just knows
if I ever if well, either one of us ever
go into cross-examination mode.
Um
>> Explain what that means for the
listeners.
>> Uh that means I'm I am asking questions
to prove a point.
Like I'm using my questions to prove my
point for me.
And so,
if I wanted Let's think of a scenario.
If I wanted to prove that, you know, you
left the garage door open. I don't know.
I'm just making something up. And she's
saying, "No, I didn't." My
cross-examination mode is
um
you know, you had you had carpool that
day, yeah?
You You left after I did, yeah? I didn't
get home before you, did I? No? You're
the one who left the garage door open.
Like you Like I'm I'm poking
I'm using my cross-examine my
questioning to prove my my point. So.
>> But isn't that effective in the
courtroom?
>> Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's what I'm
saying. It's It's not beneficial for
interpersonal relationship. It's It's
>> Only for the courtroom.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I just mean that to say that
we're both very aware of when we go into
that mode.
And as soon as we do, we're very quick
to say, "Do not cross-examine me." Oh,
yeah. Sorry. Like it's it's a It's just
a habit. You can't You can't really help
it, but we're very aware of of when
that's happening.
Um but yeah, do do I get frustrated?
Does she get frustrated? Absolutely.
Yeah.
>> One part of what I feel makes Chris Voss
Chris Voss
is
what I guess the younger kids would call
the vibes.
Like you have this vibe that you know is
your vibe. Where did you grow up, by the
way?
>> Uh small town in Iowa. I'm a small town
Iowa boy.
>> Got it. And it's I don't know where your
accent comes from. Is it I don't know
how Iowans sound.
>> No.
>> Yeah.
But it's this this tone that you have
that like if you had told me like look,
I just want to I want your couch. I'd be
like, no Chris, you can't have my couch.
I had I know it's a great couch. I
shouldn't have it, but
I just I really like this couch. And I'd
be like, gosh, you know what? You sound
so good, Chris. Here, you can you can
take it. It's um what I'm getting here,
too, is just the power of the voice and
the volume
and the tone.
Which you just have a signature style
on. And I know that you talk about that
is something that you were trained on,
you know, that late night DJ voice. So
what kind of lessons can somebody take
from slowing down their words and
lowering their volume regardless of of
their gender?
>> People connect to you a lot easier.
And the connection tends to stick.
Um if you're communicating with a high
volume words
with a lot of energy, with a lot of
emotion,
uh it has a really fast half-life. It
goes away really quickly.
>> Mhm.
>> And you want to communicate in a way
with people they kind of resonate with,
you know, it it it resonates with their
bones.
Uh they don't feel pushed.
The energy is not necessary
to continue the relationship. Um yeah, I
I learned it on a suicide hotline.
You know, then continue to learn it as a
hostage negotiator.
Ran across the hit in a therapist one
time that said that's exactly how
we get people to relax.
Uh and so then ideally the perfect
combination if you can if you can
downward reflect if you can slow down.
And you don't have to have a deep voice
like uh
women can downward reflect by simply
dropping their chin.
Downward inflection.
And then the occasional smile like it
just gives people a warm feeling. It's
something they're drawn to that they
resonate with and you put the two of
those together it it it tends to really
it really lasts. It sticks. People like
it and they feel comfortable with it.
I find that it's this
this sound when you can hear it in
somebody's voice you just think to
yourself I want them on my side.
>> Yeah.
>> I don't know what they have but
listening to it I I want them on my
side. What I try to picture often
somebody is communicating I kind of
apply a a music style. Like if I had a
CD album for this person's voice what
would I apply? You know, would it be
something very Frank Sinatra? Would it
be something super loud and crazy and
would it be hip-hop? Like what is the
vibe of this person? And if it it all
takes different walks of life. Some
people are not for other people and it's
Some people are easier to listen to. Uh
and some music is easier to listen to.
So I think you're spot on with you know,
having the ability to slow down is going
to make people more drawn to you. Is
that would that be right?
>> Yeah, drawn to you less rushed less
cornered. They feel voluntary they feel
collaborative. It just makes it easier.
Yeah, the virtual onto you with it.
>> If you enjoyed clip and want to see the
rest of the conversation, you can click
right here. Or if you want to see the
latest episode of the Jefferson Fisher
podcast, click right here and I'll meet
you there.